aber immerhin sport 13 punkte oder wie
antoine sagen würde selber butterbrezel
je nach der welt weiß dass die es gibt
das ihr zu den intelligentesten
lebewesen auf diesem planeten ziehen
da hab ich nicht gefallen sollte was
kann man da machen wir haben einerseits
die intelligenteste zuschauerschaft auf
ganz youtube wir haben andererseits aber
auch die tatsache dass diese
zuschauerschaft also ihr zeugnis bekommt
und ich persönlich finde zeugnisse sind
generell ein ultra kraft spannendes
thema weil wir oft sieht man so was von
anderen weil sie immer die sein eigenes
denken okay ich bin dann schon der
[ __ ] deswegen mag ich hatte dieses
video nicht in diesem video auf eure
zeit muss reagieren leute werde gucken
was da so drin schäden werde natürlich
als erfahrener spieler der einfach
sitzen geblieben ist natürlich auch
tipps geben wie ihr noch besser in der
schule werden könnte
let's go dieses zeugnis hier leute
stammt von einem jungen und schauen wir
mal hier rein und ihr geht es nämlich
richtig ja im fach werken textiles
gestalten arbeitete punkt mit viel
freude auf konnte aber nur wenig
ausdauer aufbringen und liest sich
leicht ablenken was ist daran ein
lustiger habe ich das fach werken
textiles gestalten nicht komplett um wie
kann man da nicht konzentriert sein er
benötigte viel hilfe beim anfertigen der
werkstücke gerade beim sticken hat der
in schwierigkeiten
ich würde sagt natürlichkeit zu über
mich selbst reden aber wenn das meint es
wäre würde wahrscheinlich bei stücken
stehen sebastian hat permanent seine
linke und rechte hand verwechselt und
konnte deswegen nicht an bord und
zusammen machen er arbeitet sehr
unkonzentriert gibt sich aber viel mühe
wie soll das aussehen so erachtet zu
übel aus strengt sich pervers also man
sieht die adern auf seiner stirn ist
richtig produziert aber er ist dabei um
konzentriert wie kann man sich viel mühe
geben und konzentriert sein kann es sein
dass der lehrer besoffen ist das nächste
zeigt dass hier stand ein mädchen ist
aus hamburg und
14 und sie schickt mir ihr zeugnis aus
der ersten klasse wird so süß seite
achtet mal drauf wie die zeugnisse
geschrieben sind da steht nicht so mathe
67 sondern das ist noch richtig
persönlich geschrieben da steht so liebe
ich freue mich dass du meiner klasse bis
es vom ersten schultag an verfolgst du
das unterrichtsgeschehen sehr aufmerksam
und lebhaft wegen deiner lebhaftigkeit
und freundlichkeit warst du in der
klasse sofort beliebt ist das geil und
wird sollte das auch so der zeitpunkt
der schullaufbahn wo die lehrer noch
richtig nett sind sondern da wollen wir
einen auch auf base später wenn man dann
irgendwie in der fünften sechsten klasse
ist er denken sich okay evans landung
freudig zu dem jetzt kann man fertig
machen guck mal hier unten alle themen
des sachunterrichts interessieren dich
und du bringst viele gute kenntnisse ein
wenn es sich um tiere oder pflanzen
handelt
im ernst leute ist es nicht verderben
das süße was zu rissen zweifels aus der
ersten klasse einer es ist so ein lied
alle haben sich lieb das ist noch bevor
kinder in die pubertät kommen und ihre
lehrer mit 30 zentimeter linealen
bedrohen wie süß als richtig cool dann
leute aber kommt irgendwann echte leben
und dann passiert das ihr wie es gesagt
habe ein mädchen auch ein bisschen älter
weil hier geht es um service von der
elften klasse aber was soll ich sagen
heute die gute wurde von ihren lehrern
komplett ruiniert die schilder zur
punkte dazu kurz zur erklärung also das
ist niedrig dass man haben kann es einen
punkt in der sechsthöchsten 15 punkte
das 1 1 und sie hat im bio 3.5 und in
mathe auch drei punkte das ist auch eine
5 womit man mit 25 nicht endlich setzen
[Musik]
aber immerhin sport 13 punkte oder 4
antoine sagen würde butter bz schüttelt
es geht weiter es sagt dass jetzt auch
von einem mädchen nur sie schreibt
darunter abitur dieses jahr wird
definitiv gut laufen okay wir haben
heute zwei punkte das 5 und bio 4 punkte
ist eine vier minus wirtschaft sechs
punkte ist auch eine vier psychologie 6
punkte auf 104 ich glaube schon dass die
zeit gekommen wo ich persönlich meine
tipps abgeben wir besser in der schule
werden könnten und dazu kann ich
eigentlich eine sache sagen seid halt
besser in der schule sollte sie doch
klingt jeder hat seine eigenen gründe
warum das funktioniert aber wenn man
regeln ist es dann auch so gemacht ist
es schon mal anfangen
okay sie können vertrauen leute ich habe
erfahrung ich habe abitur gemacht ich
habe mein studienabschluss gemacht die
hausaufgaben halt nicht aber das sollte
ich jetzt übrigens sagen wir jetzt noch
richtig spannenden vergleich denn wir
haben ein mädchen hier die ich jetzt
habe ich gerade 13 das erste zeugnis
überhaupt und ihr gerade letztes zeugnis
was sie gerade bekommen hat und das
erste zeugnis leute wie cool ist das
denn gebt euch das mal windsheimer achte
mal drauf geburts nach dem 25 45 2004
und das zeugnis ist vom 26 11 2007 die
war dreieinhalb jahre alt als sie das
zeugnis bekommen hat jetzt mal im ernst
wer gibt einer dreieinhalbjährigen
zeugnis dabei heutzutage sagt ja alles
möglich sollte bestimmt doch sowas
entschuldigen sie liebe frau meier das
doch ihr sohn fritz anton tier oder
julius maximus oder ja klar ist nicht
süß ja form eines von sechs monate
ich muss ihnen leider mitteilen dass ihr
sohn das wort papa wo falsch
ausgesprochen hat und wir uns wirklich
sorgen seine bildung machen die korrekte
betonung wären natürlich besser gewesen
als ich jetzt wirklich nicht zu direkt
sein aber da sehe ich schwarz für die
zukunft die aggression ist heavy
schreiben sogar ein wert so deine freude
sind im kindergarten sie hat ihn so
viviane und alina festspiel partner
gefunden mit denen konstruktives spiegel
was ist konstruktiv spiel was das
gegenteil destruktives spielen oder wie
dass sie sich gegenseitig die köpfe
einhauen mit dreieinhalb jahren auf
jeden fall wieder ein hammer zeug nicht
und dann wie süßes oder analyse weitere
pädagogische zielsetzung maja ist auf
einem guten weg wirklich wir schauen mal
als nächste zeugnis rein optisch kann
ich beruhigen ich habe geschaut und maja
hat später im schuljahr 2017 also zehn
jahre später mit 13 einhalb jahren 0
versäumte stunden
willst du eigentlich mal wirst du nicht
krank oder so bleibst du nicht mal eine
ganze woche zu hause meine videos zu
schauen dass von diesem video leute
vielleicht wirst du schon so weit der
natürlich immer zu hause oder auch nicht
ist für ein besseres und hat mir jetzt
nicht mache bis zum nächsten video